all right welcome everyone to choose the
evening class and the new class called
my greatest losses so you probably used
to sing my wings you know sometimes
maybe games I drew but most of the time
you know in general people like to show
their wings but today it's different so
I'll show you a game that I lost and it
was a big one it was a game that could
have made me the u.s. champion two years
ago if I had win this game no playoffs
nothing I win this game it's over clear
first so and let's take a look so I was
playing a very tough opponent of course
he Carl Nakamura in last game and he
wasn't having a good tournament he had
nothing to gain basically from this game
I mean he could just finish higher up
but he wasn't gonna surpass me or you
know or get a medal so for him it was
not very big weight for me
very big game round 11 the final around
a little bit about the tournament
situation at that moment we were tied
for first three-way tie myself Wesley so
and Alex only shook and the rest we took
a quick draw very quick draw in 30
minutes they drew and then I'll explain
or maybe hour and a half two hours
against counts could a given in a draw
right around with both games are
finished and I'll stop at that moment in
particular because you'll see I had some
chances there so you cannot plate 93 so
it with 9 of 6 3 3 t 5 so we had the
ready system of course drove would be a
great result but you know they know you
enter this three-way playoff and you
never know when you get in the playoffs
what's going to happen you know playoffs
are very hard if you have to defeat two
players so ideal you want to just win
one game and finish the tournament ideal
because you know when you get to a
three-way playoff it's very hard so
mission g4
and here okay I can play Bishop h5 I can
repeat but also I can take on f3 I have
both options and just one thing to
mention in 2014 year's championship I
was in a three-way playoff I will the
first playoff against Alex Linderman and
then I played the final match for the US
Championship against gata Kamsky and I
to the first game and lost the second
one so I'm not finishing second in that
year's championship so I believe those
playoffs and I was like okay if I cannot
do anything then it's fine but if I have
a chance I should go for the win so I
took one of three because I can retreat
as well but this is a very solid system
so I like to play this way before II 692
this visa efore by my opponent I took so
I go to this position which I thought
considering the tournament situation
wasn't bad at all because now I love
Queen b6 putting some pressure on d4
sorry before and putting pressure on b2
and you cannot develop his Bishop that
is leader so yes oh please see three
castles anything clinic you it's you
know to play solid it's good with black
and then you wait for opportunites
because most likely white is gonna start
pushing trying to get some ideas and
that's exactly what happened now look at
this setup fe8 I'll stop to the critical
moments or okay d1 I was quite happy
with my position I thought all my pieces
developed very very hard to break this
position and I upon a story to play
before okay I was quite happy to see
this move because now there's some
weaknesses on a Queen site so when
opponent weakens the position with
before what do we do how do we try to
attack that they're put in a training
mode from now on
now what are we gonna do sorry one
second part a five excellent when
opponent weakens the position you start
attacking him from the side now I was
expecting maybe perhaps a tree but his
most surprised me he took I was quite
happy to see this because look at that
now he's got two weaknesses the a
2-pound c3 pot and the Mac it was going
so well
I was playing fast and confidently okay
right around this area a couple of moves
later
so there should be two played and I
played a good move I think here let's
see if we can find my move
so again Wesley so game finish long time
ago the only game was on a shoot game
which was about to finish pretty soon
too so both games ended in a draw 95 but
he wants to play support you know he
wants to play c4 so do you want to
particularly be sitting under that c4
there okay huh
c6 pawn will be dropping in that case
the c6 pawn is in general we don't want
to play C fiber every five not yet not
yet
it's a move it's a move
white wants to play a four in this
position and then he wants to put his
roof on b1 and start putting pressure on
me okay so he is trying to play for Adi
what are we going to do to stop that
a4 and you stop it I need you to make a
move to stop a for absolutely clinic for
blocking it okay absolutely strong
position our move in my opinion now he
goes through calf b1 attacking my palm
and rook d7 I just protect the roof b3
hit late okay he really has trouble with
a to pawn so now I played look c8 we
should be 1 and what did I play here you
have to see my idea why I played at most
why did I play rook c8 guys what is the
idea I didn't just make a move right we
never make random moves every move we
play has an idea what's the idea ha-ah
db5 yes exactly
I want to play b5 two stops before and
then I can finally put that night on a
strong outpost on d5 so now I played b5
of course he goes here okay look c1 in
the first moment in a game here so what
is he wants today also plays c4 here
okay and I didn't play the best come
here I played c5 here which wasn't the
best move okay
but then he D reply correctly either to
my mouth so black to play here what is
the strongest move here to equalize the
game what would be the strongest way to
play this to equalize the game here and
I can do that right here
95 in the second-best mouth but then he
gets to play c4 and I think he's maybe
slightly better okay very slightly
better like 95 c 4 takes takes Queen 86
and then yeah very very slightly better
for him perhaps this position Mishka 3
okay then maybe he will place on May 4
okay
it's not a naughty easy move to play
though one thing I can tell you it's
neither it's not a move that just comes
into mind you know so easily but then
one once you start calculating you
realize more and more wow this move
works and it works very effectively
that's what I play in the game that's
what I played and see if I would looked
good actually but there was one problem
with it before and it takes
yeah pixie 5 and it worked out well
because he didn't responded correctly
but if he had played it correctly then I
think I'm losing upon there
don't sacrifice
no no it's a tough move to find I didn't
cross my mind I didn't think about it
too much you know I was just so excited
about c5 and I just played it and and I
guess my opponent trusted me and he just
like okay then he played another move to
surprise me and it's like we both miss
to something you know here
fantastic thinking yes the move is Queen
c4 believe it or not very powerful move
Queen c4 no this would have just shot
down everything so he has to take take
it goes here
95 yeah but I'm playing c5 next so 95
now I attacked the rook and now I paid
g6 getting my escape square looked now I
go c5 opening up the position takes rook
c5 and I'm very active here I'm at least
equal here okay yeah optically it
doesn't look great they're not doubling
up my pawns and everything but then I
just get the c5 in and break the
position takes it off c5
yeah I know I know but it's just that's
a thing you know you get such a strong
night od5 then you get your lift and
then you play c5 and I mean this
position this position looks absolutely
fine for black his bishops are not doing
that much and he's got a worry about
this c3 weakness in like if he moves the
rock I go Bishop f6 then he has to worry
about this problem at some point maybe
he's gonna have to take my knight here
and black is just too active here anyway
I think c5 a paid c5 in my opponent he
reacted interestingly he played d5 okay
but here white can get some advantage
here if he just plays pawn takes pawn
it's a hard mode to play because after
this it looks like what do you really
have here but then there is suddenly
there is this move rook cb1 and I cannot
defend the pawn properly it's it's
pretty strange but I cannot defend my PB
5 poor so he might be winning that and
then his pawns are not the greatest
pawns but they're still extra pawn so
white has advantage here okay
so white white maintained his advantage
but instead he played here and now for
sure I'm absolutely fine I took he takes
and a very important move here needed
okay he really wants to play this move
to get some control on the light squares
which move we have to do to keep the
position blocked and press
absolutely
c4 plate rook CB 1 so at this moment I
knew that I'm absolutely fine here I
have had a nice pawn structure he's got
two weak parts on a 2 and C 3 the
question is how you play for the win
here ok right around here all my
incompetence already finish their games
so I'm in this situation I feel like I'm
slightly better here a pretty safe
position to play but how to play so
let's see I want to give you a chance to
find the best plan here okay because I
had lots of ideas here if I draw this I
and we go to 3-way playoffs
if I win clear first everything is over
so the problem I have right now my
bishop is a little bit loose on his
seven and when you have a position like
this you want to find a square that is
gonna be the most solid square
okay what would be the most solid square
for your Bishop absolutely and I should
have played Bishop f8 I mean with
accurate play I think white equalizes
here but for example look if you play
now Queen d1 now I just the key is to
understand that's where I've missed in
the game the key is to keep the Queen's
on the board
okay if you take on the fiber dub of the
rooks and you're losing a piece a 4r
okay one may be dropping the Queen drops
the Queen yeah so I don't want to take
and suddenly find myself in trouble
quenice an a4
and now this if I'm putting pressure and
this looks pretty comfortable for block
because I have a lot of pressure
a-five I can just go to be seller I mean
the part just went couple of moves and
how it's stuck it's not going anywhere
I've got a pressure on the bishop I can
double off the rooks I mean it's very
comfortable for block disposition
I should have played that move Bishop f8
and but I think the only way after
Bishop f8 is to play the small Bishop d2
that Bishop is really bad and it's
important to try to play this month we
should be too quick imagine but you have
to give up the pawn takes Queen was here
now threatening okay one trying to trap
I think this is how maybe they achieve
the draw here Bishop e3 Queen c3 they
should be for Queen D 3 into 3 takes
Bishop f6 some something like this or
sorry perhaps you're just look do you
want they will take on the 3 ok I'm
absolutely not in any risk to lose this
position I'll be extra fun but at least
this way we're going to that three-way
playoff they know next day yeah it's
just it's a good lesson to learn you
know when you have a loose piece don't
put on a squares that still gonna be a
little bit loose you know put it
somewhere there issues for sure you
don't have to worry about it Bishop on a
favor will be protected I would never
have to worry about any background
issues and that would have been much
better
I played Bishop d6 again keep in mind I
really like my position here so I was
like I was happy to be in this situation
I thought I have h4 h5 five years coming
up of course there's a little tactic we
should be 5 takes Knight d5 and Bishop
takes g3 check winning the rock
so but now he plays here queen d1 and
this is where the big mistake okay the
the mistake that cost me cost me a lot
so I I knew I shouldn't have traded
Queens but you know I even had my hand I
didn't want to exchange I was gonna play
the right move but I end up exchanging
Queens which with the correct place
should be a dross - but it's you know
from slightly better position now I'm
going to a slide the words in game and
to defend accurately so it's it's always
very unpleasant when there is a big
switch like that in a game so in this
position black must keep the Queens on
the board okay and here I should have
just simply played the move that we've
been discussing Queen a7 with the idea
of Bishop c5 okay you cannot take this
pawn because if you take then after
Bishop c5 you're gonna be losing some
material here
so Queen eighty-seven Bishop f3 is the
best move here then we get that position
again Bishop c5 attacking on f2 Kim G -
loke 8 group 1 b2
I hope t7 again but the pressure Bishop
cannot move me - I text so he has to
play a bookie - here it'll take C -
Bishop takes it to and now Queen eight -
[ __ ] piece hanging so Bishop f3 and
again I probably have to just go back
Bishop here and take 75 attend attend it
looks like it's probably still gonna be
close to draw me this Bishop is kind of
misplaced but there's just not enough
material to to do much here I do have
this interesting mode Oh Queen a eight
threatening rook takes you one the White
has the only move here
and no longer this is a threat because
King had taken well there is a threat of
Queen Queen to h1 at some point so I
probably just put your six most likely
it will be a draw but now things become
really problematic little bit because
now again I took took and I went back we
should be seven so again the better try
probably would have bid to play Bishop
a3 to just prevent its opponent has a
strong pollinate file so I should just
instead of playing here I should just
try to prevent him from pushing the pawn
this would have been easier way for me
Bishop a three and it's not easy to push
and again if you place Bishop d5 you
gotta watch out for some pins okay
some serious pins alright
I play Bishop e7 and now he pushed rook
a8 he pushed Bishop if I might add Oh
Cameron and windows palm probably just
gonna be a draw I know now okay one he's
not he's not making it easy
that should we say he's defending this
point and here again this a pawn is not
really gonna go anywhere at the moment
so I should have just played King f8 you
know King f8 bringing my king in a
little bit closer and then try to win
the pot King f8 King f8 g for h6 should
be able to make a draw here no problem I
went here directly and that allows the
capture I could have played this
differently then it's better to have the
king so I took now he goes B should be
killed and he ran unfortunately my king
was over here I would have been able to
play the move Bishop I would have been
able to play the movie should be six but
here's I couldn't play B should be six
anymore because of capture if I capture
with the bishop it's I get pinned very
unpleasant pin and then Bishop e3 is
coming I'm losing material and if I take
with a rope Bishop e3 and I cannot take
background checkmate okay so it's
problem
so now I regret it you know moving my
route because there's no need to do that
I mean I'm coming there next so just
bring the king in and next move I will
go for the same idea and I don't have to
worry any of these background ideas and
most likely I'll secure the draw here I
mean it's not that difficult this takes
takes I take it now again if given this
position from a scratch
you know black should be able to try to
hold this you know like you know good
chances for a job but from a slightly
better position now I know chances to
win have to suffer and yeah it's quite
difficult so I played h6 Bishop III
attack in the rook okay six and again
I'm hoping to get the city power but
egos here I don't think I can defend the
c4 pawn the bishop c7r okay six my best
bet is to trade the bishops off here so
Bishop d6 I think this this is fine here
my king is little bit further now rook
takes c4 Bishop e5
rook see it's okay so we reach this
position and here again this is a move
that it's a very natural move to play
here and I should be trying to get some
space on the Queen side sorry on the
Kings side because so otherwise he's
gonna start pushing so instead of
playing the move rook a tree which I did
I should have start with G five years
gaining some space okay
g5 c-4 rook goes behind a pawn let's say
c6 qg6 and it's incredibly hard it's
gonna be incredibly hard to win this
position I mean it's just one pass pawn
it's not going anywhere my bishop is
perfectly placed in the middle my rook
is behind a passed pawn where it needs
to be how is it gonna make progress here
it's incredibly hard to win a position
like this I can put the pawn on f6 I can
play h5 at some point put the King on f5
yeah but I didn't do that unfortunately
this was important after do k3
immediately and now it please c4 again
it's not too late to play this f4 but I
didn't just put up a good resistance
here it was just very pity but I didn't
again three five minutes to be played
and now I allowing this it was important
to put the roof behind upon now have six
and now unfortunately when I play if six
I allow him to cut my king
so my king can I go to a five now c3
rook c3 c5 and now the problem is my
king
I really miss play the same game I mean
I could have just had this position with
the pommel and g5 imagine with the power
on g5 we're talking about completely
different scenario now my king is stuck
I cannot move it and he is just trying
to bring his king to d2 now he has a
very simple plan he wants to bring the
key to d2 so I had to go here Roxy for
King before now King got active because
if I had the pollo g5 here right
I will put my King on a5 and he could
never reach there so yeah this is
already lost I think g4 now my bishop
got locked so I couldn't
yeah now it's just basically gonna be a
check and look see six covers so if I
got okay six a quiz and if I could look
secure we'll just say check losing the
game very tough game as you can see but
lot to learn from you know lot to learn
from in a sense that you know when there
is a transition from you know preferable
position to a difficult endgame you
still have to play it tough and now
looking back I mean when I got to the
same game I'm just you know like like
this position I mean there's no need to
move the rook on 87 right now because
there's no threat so bring the King
closer right we know the rule we have to
have the king closer so bring it here
you plays three four and then only then
we put the rook here so let's say you
place Bishop be Q then we will go here
takes again take take here I'm wondering
if I can even just take look takes rook
takes rook takes rook takes okay so
that's it takes
and
I mean look see if I might Bishop fb6
even if yes yeah I take and I take your
Bishop on v2
yeah I was looking at that idea if you
take me here I take you and our guys and
you take here and then I go here and I
want this pawn it's gonna be a draw so
yeah I think this is just great I don't
see any problem I don't see any problem
really holding this position
okay maybe here okay ideas to get the
rook but still look we also have some
ideas there so maybe just there should
be six now traders look a look actually
going to a two side play here efficiency
five
look
again it's
yeah you might get some rockin game like
this just achieve a drawer not because
of the weaknesses too many weaknesses in
the camp maybe you can go King f3 okay
then I will King g7 which should be
three I take take okay you can have the
C pod and have your H bar and it's gonna
be a draw
okay well tough tough one
have fun well of course but if the
biggest mistake was trading Queens yeah
this was I had some nightmares about
this McLean he won because I there was
even a video of it there was a YouTube
in a life life and it shows that I'm
really ready to play this move backwards
reaching day 70 now there's no square
and then I something stops and instead
of making the correct move trusting my
intuition I start to overthink my move
spend a couple of more minutes and I end
up taking because really wasted time but
I think it would be very nice idea I'm
just curious you know like if what would
have happen here because if my opponent
would have continued to play
aggressively for a win if it does then I
have great chances to win if it tries to
defend but for him again droids not it's
nothing you know for him he couldn't win
the tournament with a win or a draw for
him it was more like he really wanted to
win - which was good for me because that
gave me a chances so again Bishop f3
bishops 5 the plum and I just wanted to
show you the pawn once again yeah this
is a problem because it gets it gets
pinned so I can even play the move rook
C to d8 and they capture Bishop d3 so
this is some serious problems here you
cannot take the pawn so here you should
see five so this is it yeah rook e8 now
putting pressure on the bishop double of
the rooks and again like imagine he has
to come up with this news give up the
pawn just to try to make a draw here I
mean I was he's down upon him he's not
playing for a win she takes rook Queen
cannot take because he wanna sing
we Nate threatened group takes e1 and
amazingly at asking f1 looks like saves
the day yeah I mean I can grab the g6
wait
the you will miss this tactic rookie 5
wait it doesn't work oh wait actually
sorry clean after doesn't work guys look
do you want we're winning the material
now because Rudy clear we just take a
look at five we just take so that means
it's not so easy to untangle this you
know let me tangled up you know how to
handle this do you see away yeah I have
better structured I have better
structure because that to Pond Island
cs3 yes that siliceous question about
structures you know like here I have a
better structure I have to pawn islands
yeah three pounds on the one side and
between a center then he's got this he's
got three pawn islands okay so but you
know he really had to do something like
this because if he is let's say he tries
to I don't know play he doesn't want to
give up the pawn I mean I mean I'm gonna
double up the rooks next on this bishop
and the bishop moves f2 is hanging this
pawn on c4 this is an excellent setup
nice diagonal pressure here as well
enough and this pause a really
restricting and I double up the rooks I
have some h5 ideas as well
I imagine this is the best time to give
up if it doesn't want to do that then
maybe Queen d2 he has to play but again
it is it's unclear how how how to get a
piece out here h5
yeah but but that's the thing if he
doesn't want to go for that line to give
up upon he's gonna have to play this
position but there is no chances to play
for a win here
I mean cannot really you know I really
don't see because the pressure is so
that the pressure only one gonna be
there the pressure on f2 is still there
it's much much easier got that B file
but there is no way to enter anywhere or
do anything with it yeah so this was the
this was the game this was the game and
when we traded Queens yeah this was a
bad decision I was already getting a
long time too you know and I went for
this position and here of course
opponents only thing is to push the pawn
right what should I try to do to prevent
that Rd Bishop III stop that pawn from
moving make it more difficult for the
opponent to advance the pawn because at
the end of the day I still had a good
structure guys and if he cannot push the
a pawn how is he gonna win the game if
the only plan is to push the a pound to
get some concha play I mean there there
is a way for him to remove this Bishop
Bishop a3 like the LA one of the lines
is h4 here with the threat of some [ __ ]
page stream of not a easy thing to see
rook a7 apparently is good
they should be 55555 and I just go rook
c8
and then I will move this bishop and
take on a - okay still probably gonna be
down upon but throwing chances here but
even the way I play I think it's
reasonable I don't think I played just
just this next decision was strange
enough to to put the rukon a7 where I
don't have the control
he still has to work for it take taking
defy so what wake one more move let him
do whatever move g4 h6 bit should be -
okay when the bishop gets there now
Bishop wants to come in I gotta just
lets make decision okay the shorty five
has to take because if you go Bishop e3
I think I just take so you take I have
to be careful here there's a trap if I
take like this there's a look be a
defend take take a check okay but I
don't have to fall for that you know you
should takes now I'll take this pawn you
should be five I just take take take on
so probably have to play the specialty
formal and
yeah
I can just top it there's a check if and
this is not so good King has to go back
check and you know I might be taking
over you know with ninety two threats
and stuff so yeah this is yeah obviously
not the right way to play so here he had
to take take again rook da doesn't work
it's very important I've roped the eight
and d2 is hanging so as to take bishop
takes it should be six threatening okay
two ideas again f2 pond needs to be
protected
the good news is for me I have this I
have this the weak pawn on H Street to
work with so I can always do maybe
something about that so okay you can
play kinky - maybe but problem what is
the route going guys know we're trapped
piece C so it's we discover more ideas
you know so that's why he has to go
Bishop III take King takes if he wants
to keep a good structure you go here
draw if you take that with pawn I mean I
can I can play a move like okay four
if I really want to do that just you
know that's a little bit more passive
difference but I think we should do it
because once your King gets moving I can
try to get behind it so should be able
to hold yeah the most important thing I
learned is even if it's a very very
important last game let's say right
you're playing you still have to try to
you know not to worry about the
standings tournament situation just try
to play it the best game you can and I
think in the beginning part I did I
liked quite a few of my moves in this
game I thought my opening was very solid
very good for a last round game and I
waited for him to open up which he did I
take now I went here another nice move
Queenie for fixing it then I was playing
quite fast too you know quite fast quite
confidently now I will be three Roxie
eight
I like this b5 very positional trying to
stop c4 he goes here now okay this was a
difficult moment here another nice one
would have been Quincy fourth this would
have been a nice move to just shut down
the game but a camera here see if I
wasn't the best and after c4 another
very portable c4 you have to find this
cannon because otherwise he's gonna play
c4 he's gonna play c4 takes Queen c4 and
the bishop is gonna be very strong by
playing this I'm keeping his both Bishop
shut down the light square Bishop is
kind of you know it's attacking but it's
not attacking anything on the on this
side and the bishop only one cannot move
anywhere
so after c4 it's still probably close to
equal but already little bit more
preferable for the block okay it's rich
a present sorry white yeah g3f to see
three years here's three pounds we
cannot win the pants at the moment I
think the the a to pun is a big target
also we cannot win I mean if you traded
bishops I think in fact at the moment I
think my bishop is pretty good here I
don't have a way to trade that bishop I
think one Bishop on c5 is quite active
in those lines that we looked at it I
mean look at this position Suresh if I
play this like this sorry Amy my bishop
is better than his
C and now his bishop is mainly just
doing defensive work and my bishop is
actually you know controlling a lot of
squares but also putting a lot of
pressure here yeah something like this
is yeah if they fan I just go h5 and you
know try try to go for a win here
doubling up the rooks is another idea I
can do here I mean computer was even
showing like this
he was just computer was just playing
like this then playing g5 King g7 I
analyze this very deeply g5 King g7 it
just says why cannot do anything you
just gradually improve the position if
you play like this and but the correct
way is to clear up beat this line but
then you're forced to give update upon
and there's absolutely no no chances in
this position okay well thank you guys
for attending this class and we will see
you next time okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]